so one of the lines that wasn't working
is our the woman walked in she was the
bride to be and she would come in and go
hey you guys are drinking beers before
the wedding can I have a beer and then
my role as the best friend was like of
course but they wanted it so that like
that of course really showed that we had
a friendship so we do it like 19
different ways oh sure thing sis of
course all these reads that the
Network's giving me so Ellie Gould's
playing a blind man he's standing behind
me with a dog and he's playing a blind
guy looking off the side they walk away
it's like two in the morning and he
leans down and he goes improv one and I
go yeah and he goes yeah trust me improv
one it'll be the one they use she comes
in she goes hey can I get a beer and I
go is a duck's ass water tight get in
here and it gets a huge laugh right
great showrunner comes up to me
smiling gets right up to me I like
ghoul's right behind me he goes you are
[__] me in the [__] ass right now
I got bent over and [__] in the ass by
you in front of all the [__] execs
and he walks away Elliott Gould's still
playing a guy and got blind guy and just
goes sorry